Ngày Bây chiến tháng 6 là ngày Bí sống sự kiện đặc biệt đối với lịch sử rất nuốt và sân tộc Việt Nam.
Đó là ngày xin của chụt tệ khổ chi mình, lãnh tụi thiên tại Cuộc Đàng và nhân dân Việt Nam,
người thời vi đại của các mạng Việt Nam, anh hùng sài phóng sân tộc, sang anh vàng hóa thị sửi.
Ngày Bây Tảm tháng 6 đã bự nhiên chính trong bún miệ sống, trên trận nhất bảo kêu khốt, đang một bài bảo gốc đặc biệt với tửa đi.
Cuộc hồ chi mình với xanh tộc Việt Nam, bài bảo đã chính thức thường bắng ngày xin của chụt tệ khồ chi mình, ngày mây chiến tháng 6, 1.
Này mây chiến tháng 6 là một nghiên chính trong bún miệ sống, tại Bắc Bộ Phu, các đồng chỉ trong tượng vụ chung hương, trong chính phu,
đại biểu tiểu như thủ đô, đoàn đại biểu nhân dân nằm bộ và nhiều bán ngành đã đến chúc mừng xin nhật mát.
Mát đã chỗ bài chung với thất chảo tử như và nói chuyện với các tệ biểu nằm bộ.
Đáp lại tình cảm của mọi người Bắc nói, thật ra các mát tội đầy làm tò sinh dật tôi, chứ tội năm bị sống chưa có gì đáng chúc thôi.
Cũng hãy còn như thành nghiệp cả mà chứ các anh tắt chỉ, chứ cạnh với buổi ở bác đầy.
Tòi thật thể làm sống hồ rằng trong năm chưa được thái bình.
Nằm một nghiên chính trong bún miệ bệ giới lúc của kháng chiến lăn dọng xa cả nước,
xin nhật Bắc diễn ra tại một tế điểm biến bật trên chính phu hồ ở sân dường tuyên quan.
Tì các đồng chỉ phục vụ mang bó phà dường đến chúc mừng xin nhật mát.
Mát đã đề gì, dành như bông a đó để viễn đồng chiếu hạng văn lâu.
Gửi cấp dưỡng thần thiết vừa qua đời dò xuất dễ.
Còn như lần dò cộng bún tổ chức lấy mừng xin nhật, Bắc đã làm bài thơ không đề,
chả lời vô số cán bộ để gì tổ chức xin nhật Bắc.
Vì nước nên chương ý đến nhà, năm bị chính tuổi bánh chư dạ.
Chờ cho kháng chiến thành công đáng, bản xe ăn mừng xin nhật tài.
Bà ngày bây chiến tháng năm, Bắc tử vi công tát hoặc xuống cửa sở tham bà có nước dần.
Bắc cũng tử viết thử, người điện tà mất độ bà đồng chỉ cửa quan bà thể trong nước,
và bầu bản khúc tế đã hát sản trong người những tình tạm thân thiết.
Đầu tháng năm, năm, năm, năm, năm, năm, năm, năm, năm, năm, năm, năm, năm, năm, năm,
trong sống mi chính người tiếp các cán bộ phân phòng các đồng chỉ trong bộ chính chỉ,
và một số đồng chỉ vì viên trung hương đến chúc thọng.
Lấy mừng thọ bác diễn ra cho khu khí đầm mắm đồng buổi.
Nhưng không ngày đi, đó hó là dịt kị nghiệm xin nhật Bắc, lần phối cùng.
Chính dở sản, ngày mấy chính tháng năm, năm, năm, năm, năm, năm, năm,
trong sống mi chính, xin nhật lần thứ bởi mi chính, Bắc là người vào bản năm biệt,
xem và chình xửa những lời dận dò khu khuy cùng trong bản dí chúc để lại cho toàn đà, toàn dân.
Người lưu đón xin nhật bằng sự cần bánh làm việc.
Người còn nói với anh em phục vụ, tháng năm là tháng ý điểm xin nhật bác,
mắt phải là việc nhiều hơn. Lối sống dàn gì tháng chào của bác, là cả một nét đẹp bánh hoán.
Không dồng thời là bản lính bánh hoán khu khuy đầy.